I was talking to some homicide detectives in Chicago. And they told me that, contrary to what you might have heard, most criminals do not actually return to the scene of the crime. Arsonists do. They like to watch the flames. Serial killers sometimes do, but they're crazy. Other kinds of criminals aren't really known for going back to the place where the crimes happened. Like thieves, for example.
我曾与芝加哥的一些凶杀案侦探交谈过。他们告诉我，与你可能听说过的相反，大多数罪犯实际上并不会回到犯罪现场。纵火犯会。他们喜欢看火焰。连环杀手有时会回去，但他们是疯子。其他类型的罪犯并不以重返犯罪现场而闻名。比如小偷，就是这样。
If you want to see thieves returning to the scene of the crime, you pretty much have to go to Florida. Beautiful, sunny, Florida. For instance, to a Kangaroo Express convenience store in Pomona Park.
如果你想看到小偷重返犯罪现场，你差不多得去佛罗里达。美丽的、阳光明媚的佛罗里达。例如，去波莫纳公园的一家袋鼠快运便利店。
I'm literally walking back and forth in front of the store, holding a sign. A big heavy sign, at that.
我正真真切切地在店门口来回走动，手里举着一个牌子。而且还是一个又大又重的牌子。
And what does this sign say?
这个牌子上写着什么？
"I stole from this store."
“我从这家店偷过东西。”
This 18-year-old spoke with one of our show's producers, Lisa Pollak, who went with a tape recorder to watch her serve the sentence that she was given for theft. In Putnam County, Florida, if you're convicted of misdemeanor theft, which means shoplifting anything less than $300, Judge Peter Miller will send you back to the scene of the crime, to carry this sign.
这位18岁的女孩接受了我们节目制片人丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）的采访，丽莎带着录音机去观看她执行因盗窃而被判处的刑罚。在佛罗里达州普特南县，如果你因轻罪盗窃被定罪，也就是偷窃价值低于300美元的任何东西，彼得·米勒法官（Judge Peter Miller）就会让你回到犯罪现场，举着这个牌子。
Isn't that quite embarrassing? It is embarrassing.
那不是很尴尬吗？确实很尴尬。
For 12 years since Judge Miller first started ordering these people to carry signs, the person goes with the perps is site supervisor Kathy Pekrul.
自从米勒法官开始判决这些人举牌以来的12年里，负责监督罪犯执行的人一直是现场主管凯西·佩克鲁尔（Kathy Pekrul）。
I would say most of them are embarrassed. Really embarrassed. I've have had two or three girls that just cried their way all the way through it.
我想说他们大多数人都感到尴尬。真的很尴尬。我有两三个女孩整个过程都在哭。
OK, now you're blocking your face with the sign, so you can't do that, OK? You ready? All right, go that way first. Do not say anything rude to anybody. No matter what they say to you, don't answer back if it's rude.
好了，你现在用牌子挡住了脸，所以你不能那样做，好吗？准备好了吗？好的，先往那边走。不要对任何人说粗鲁的话。无论他们对你说什么，如果他们的话很粗鲁，就不要回应。
For two hours the guilty march back and forth with the sign. Kathy brings a lawn chair for herself and a book. Enough people get this sentence that Kathy says she is the best-read person in Putnam County.
罪犯们会举着牌子来回走动两个小时。凯西会为自己带一把折叠椅和一本书。被判这种刑罚的人足够多，以至于凯西说她是普特南县读书最多的人。
It was 120 people last year. Occasionally, Kathy says that some passers-by see what's going on and approach her to complain that this punishment seems too humiliating. And when that happens, she tells them politely that she will let the judge now know they feel, though, honestly, I'm not really sure she needs to go to the trouble.
去年有120人。凯西说，偶尔会有路人看到正在发生的事情，并过来抱怨这种惩罚似乎太羞辱人了。当这种情况发生时，她会礼貌地告诉他们，她会把他们的感受转达给法官，不过说实话，我不确定她是否有必要费那个劲。
Too humiliating? Hey, they want to think that, that's fine. That doesn't bother me. I'm going to humiliate the one that's carrying that sign.
太羞辱人了吗？嘿，他们想那么想就那么想吧。这对我没影响。我要羞辱的是那个正在举牌的人。
This is Judge Peter Miller. A man who has sentenced hundreds of people to carry the sign over the past 12 years. I liked talking to Judge Miller. I like any public official who gets an idea for how to serve the public from the newspaper. Which is where he got the idea for the sign.
这位就是彼得·米勒法官。在过去12年里，他判处了数百人举牌。我喜欢和米勒法官交谈。我喜欢任何从报纸上获得服务公众灵感的政府官员。他就是从那里得到的举牌这个主意。
Some judge up north did it. I liked it, so I did it.
北方有位法官这么干过。我喜欢这个主意，所以我也照做了。
What'd you like about it?
你喜欢它哪一点？
Well, I like the fact that you're getting-- somebody's out there and the public's actually looking at a thief. They've got caught, and somebody's trying to do something about it.
嗯，我喜欢这样一个事实：有人在大街上，公众真的在看着一个小偷。他们被抓住了，而且有人正在为此采取行动。
Wait, why is that the important part, that the public sees it? Like I would think it would be more important to get through to the criminal, you know what I mean?
等等，为什么这很重要，公众看到它很重要？我以为让罪犯认识到错误会更重要，你明白我的意思吗？
Well, you want to get through to the criminal, and at the same time the public, too, who are out there looking saying, I don't want to be doing that. Not in front of all these people.
嗯，你想让罪犯认识到错误，同时公众也在那里看着，心想，我可不想那样做。在这么多人面前丢人。
Oh, I see, it's a preventative thing?
噢，我明白了，这是一种预防措施？
Yes sir.
是的，先生。
For the judge, this is the heart of the whole deal. He remembers back when he was young, when somebody got caught stealing it was shameful. People looked down on it. That sense of shame just seems to be gone among so many people who he sees from the bench these days. When I suggest to him that the punishment he's come up with seems kind of biblical, he's got no problem with that.
对法官来说，这是整个事情的核心。他记得他年轻的时候，如果有人被抓到偷东西，那是很可耻的。人们会瞧不起这种行为。这种羞耻感在如今他从法官席上看到的许多人身上似乎已经消失了。当我向他建议说他想出的这种惩罚看起来有点像圣经里的做法时，他对此一点意见都没有。
Well maybe that's what we need a little bit more. There's nothing wrong with a little bit of religion. Nothing's wrong with that. Could there be more of that?
嗯，也许这就是我们需要多一点的东西。有一点宗教信仰没什么不好的。那没什么不对。能多一点吗？
What do you hope is going through their heads when they're walking with that sign?
你希望他们在举着牌子走路的时候脑子里在想什么？
I hope that what's going through their heads is, Lord have mercy. I'm being shamed. I don't like this. And I'm not doing it anymore. Because the public can see those people out there walking, and it really tickles them.
我希望他们脑子里想的是，上帝慈悲啊。我正在受辱。我不喜欢这样。我再也不做这种事了。因为公众能看到那些人走在那里，这真的让他们感到好笑。
She's sitting in the car laughing at me. She lucky I'm under supervision because if I wasn't, I'd slap that [? head. ?]
她坐在车里对着我笑。她算走运，我正在受监管，不然的话，我会打掉她的[？头。？]
In fact, the people that Lisa talked to in Florida who walked by this 18-year-old, they definitely did seem to be tickled.
事实上，丽莎在佛罗里达采访的那些路过这个18岁女孩的人，他们看起来确实觉得很好笑。
I mean I think it's marvelous punishment. Yes. I think it's great.
我的意思是，我认为这是一种绝妙的惩罚。是的。我认为这很棒。
Like this couple from out of town
比如这对从外地来的夫妇。
Paying a fine's too easy.
交罚款太容易了。
I wish we could do that up our way in Delaware. I think the civil liberties union would be all over them-- "You don't have a right."
我希望我们在特拉华州也能这么做。我想公民自由联盟会找上他们的麻烦——“你没有这个权利。”
I wish they would do it with people on the highway. Especially speeders.
我希望他们能对公路上的人也这样。尤其是超速驾驶的人。
Wait, how would that work on the highway?
等等，这在公路上怎么行得通？
Well, instead of letting them pay a fine, let them walk out there and say, "I endangered your life."
嗯，别让他们交罚款，让他们站在路边说，“我危及了你的生命。”
You mean have them stand on the shoulder of the road?
你是说让他们站在路肩上？
Well, yeah.
嗯，是的。
Maybe they could have a sign on the car for the driver.
也许他们可以给司机在车上贴个牌子。
Yes, yes! Excellent.
是的，是的！太棒了。
During the two hours as the 18-year-old marches back and forth, she actually doesn't get that much abuse from people. It's nowhere as bad as she thought. Some cars honk at her. People point. A woman shoots her a disgusted look. Two old men stand in the store, arms folded, and watch her, amused. But most people don't say anything at all. In Putnam County, after all, this is not an unusual sight. They look at her sign. They walk by. And she chats, cheerfully, with lots of people. She waves to a guy passing by.
在这两个小时里，18岁的女孩来回走动，她并没有受到人们太多的辱骂。情况远没有她想象的那么糟。有些车会对她按喇叭。人们指指点点。一个女人向她投去厌恶的目光。两个老人在店里抱臂看着她，觉得很有趣。但大多数人什么都没说。毕竟在普特南县，这并不是什么罕见的景象。他们看着她的牌子。他们走过去。而她愉快地与许多人聊天。她向路过的一个人挥手。
What's up, Boo? How you been doing?
怎么了，Boo？你最近怎么样？
Another guy flirts with her. Tells her, "Keep your chin up." Somebody yells from his car, "You should hold a sign that says, I was the only one who got caught." And anytime that strangers do stop and read the sign, or try to talk to her, this is what she says--
另一个人跟她调情。对她说，“把头抬起来。”有人从车里喊道：“你应该举一个写着‘我是唯一一个被抓住的’的牌子。”每当陌生人停下来读牌子，或者试图跟她说话时，她就会这么说——
It's OK. I was stealing milk for my little girl. This is why this happened. I was stealing milk for my little girl. That's why I'm holding this sign here.
没关系。我是在为我的小女儿偷牛奶。这就是为什么会发生这种事。我是在为我的小女儿偷牛奶。这就是我为什么举着这个牌子的原因。
Her little girl is one. In fact, according to the police report, she and a friend were arrested for taking the following-- one package of Oreo Cakesters, one Twix bar, one Milky Way, one package of M&M's, one can of Dr. Pepper, and, yes, one pint of milk. But keep in mind, she is just a kid. She's a teenager. She's just a kid, right? So, yes, she's not only unrepentant, just like the judge says he sees from the bench, she's also kind of indignant.
她的女儿才一岁。事实上，根据警方报告，她和一个朋友被捕是因为拿了以下东西——一包奥利奥夹心饼干，一根特趣巧克力棒，一根银河巧克力棒，一包M&M豆，一罐Dr. Pepper，还有，没错，一品脱牛奶。但请记住，她只是个孩子。她还是个青少年。她只是个孩子，对吧？所以，是的，她不仅像法官在法官席上所说的那样毫无悔意，她甚至还有点愤愤不平。
See I was the only one that got caught. I was the only one that was stupid enough to let the camera see me. And then them two little boys in there, they're the ones that made me go to jail. Excuse me but--
你看，我是唯一一个被抓住的。我是唯一一个笨到让摄像头拍到的人。然后那两个在里面的小男孩，是他们害我进了监狱。不好意思，但是——
You mean the store managers?
你是说店经理吗？
Yes, that would be them, but I don't like them. Them bitches in there, they didn't have to take me to jail. See they chose to take me to jail. Which all they had to do was give us a trespassing warning. That's all they had to do.
是的，就是他们，我不喜欢他们。那几个贱人，她们没必要把我送进监狱。你看，她们选择把我送进监狱。她们本来只需要给我们一个非法入侵警告就行了。她们本来只需要做这些。
If this is meant to be a learning experience, tell me what you think you learned?
如果这被视为一种学习经历，告诉我你认为你学到了什么？
Honestly? I didn't learn anything. I might sound stupid or dumb, but honestly I didn't learn anything. I'll steal again. This doesn't solve anything.
老实说吗？我什么也没学到。我听起来可能很蠢，但老实说我什么也没学到。我还会再偷的。这解决不了任何问题。
Are you worried about saying that?
你担心说这些话吗？
No.
不。
On radio?
在广播里说？
No, I'm not worried about a thing. Because no one knows nothing about it.
不，我什么都不担心。因为没人知道关于这件事的任何情况。
The county doesn't keep statistics on how many people who carry the sign get caught again for stealing. But probation officer Kathy Pekrul says that maybe only 20% of the people who she sees carrying the sign seemed totally unrepentant. Of course, what the judge wants is such a delicate thing to try to force on to somebody. He wants them to return to the scene of the crime, and have this poetic moment of realization. He wants them to take stock of their lives. He wants them to change. And you just can't predict when that's going to happen. Kathy Pekrul remembers this one young man who she took to carry the sign in front of a liquor store that he'd robbed in Crescent City. He spent the whole time joking with people and carrying on.
县里没有统计有多少举牌的人会再次因偷窃被抓。但缓刑官凯西·佩克鲁尔说，她所见的举牌人中可能只有20%看起来是完全没有悔意的。当然，法官想要强加给别人的东西是如此微妙。他希望他们回到犯罪现场，有一个诗意般的顿悟时刻。他希望他们反思自己的生活。他希望他们做出改变。而你无法预测什么时候会发生这种情况。凯西·佩克鲁尔记得有个年轻人，她带他去他抢劫过的一家克雷森特城的酒类商店前举牌。他全程都在和人们开玩笑，举止放肆。
His whole family came out and they kept riding around the block and laughing at him, and stopping and taking pictures of him, and he was posing with sign.
他的全家都出来了，他们不断地绕着街区开车并嘲笑他，还停下来给他拍照，他则摆姿势和牌子合影。
And he thought it was funny too?
他也觉得这很有趣吗？
Yes he did. And I would have told you, if you had asked me, that he was one of the ones that would repeat. I would have been sure of it.
是的，他觉得。如果你问我，我肯定会告诉你，他是那种会重犯的人。我对此很确定。
Three or four years later, she was back at the same liquor store with another perp, and that guy walked up to her and she didn't remember his name. But she definitely remembered how much fun he had had when he had carried the sign.
三四年后，她带着另一个罪犯回到同一家酒类商店，那个人向她走来，她记不起他的名字了。但她绝对记得他举牌时玩得有多开心。
So we were talking. And he was just-- we were just talking-- and then he said to me he wanted me to know that he was on the straight and narrow, I think he said, or something to that effect. And that he had finished a criminal justice degree and he was a policeman for someone. And this was a surprise. Very surprised.
所以我们在谈话。他只是——我们当时正在交谈——然后他对我提到，他想让我知道他已经走上了正道，我想他是这么说的，或者类似的话。他还说他已经拿到了刑事司法学位，现在是某人的警察了。这真是一个惊喜。非常惊讶。
So you know, you never know. Because I would have told you for sure he was going to repeat. Basically, it's very much like this girl today.
所以你知道，你永远不会知道。因为我肯定会告诉你他会重犯的。基本上，这和今天这个女孩的情况非常相似。
Well, today on our program, we joined several different people in this very fraught situation. Where they returned to the scenes of various crimes of various sorts.
好吧，今天在我们的节目中，我们和几个不同的人一起参与了这个非常令人紧张的局面。他们回到了各种不同犯罪现场。
From WBEZ Chicago, It's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
Our program today is recorded at the Chicago Theater in downtown Chicago and at the Skirball Center for the Performing Arts in New York University, where it is being beamed to 430 movie theaters around the country right now.
我们今天的节目是在芝加哥市中心的芝加哥剧院和纽约大学的斯基博尔表演艺术中心录制的，目前正通过卫星传输到全国430家电影院。
From the Brunswick 10 theater in Maine, to the AMC Mission Valley Theater in San Diego, to the Capitol 14 Theater in Olympia, Washington, to the City North and River East and Webster Place theaters in our beloved Chicago.
从缅因州的布伦瑞克10电影院，到圣地亚哥的AMC使命谷电影院，到华盛顿奥林匹亚的国会14电影院，再到我们钟爱的芝加哥的城市北部、东河和韦伯斯特广场电影院。
We have stories today of crimes in traffic, in a family, in a marriage, crimes with God, Mike Birbiglia, Dan Savage, musical guest Joss Whedon, and much, much more.
我们今天的故事涉及交通犯罪、家庭犯罪、婚姻犯罪、亵渎神灵，还有迈克·比比利亚（Mike Birbiglia）、丹·萨维奇（Dan Savage）、音乐嘉宾乔斯·韦登（Joss Whedon），以及更多内容。
Stay with us.
请继续收听。
Act One. D-U-WHY?
第一幕。酒驾（D-U-WHY）？
So this guy committed a crime and it had huge consequences for this first person we're bringing out, Mike Birbiglia, and then the best way to describe what happened is Mike found he could not leave the scene of the crime.
所以这个家伙犯了罪，这对我们要请出的第一位嘉宾迈克·比比利亚造成了巨大的影响，而描述所发生事情的最好方式是，迈克发现他无法离开那个犯罪现场。
Please welcome Mike Birbiglia.
欢迎迈克·比比利亚。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Two years ago I'm in Los Angeles, and I'm at my friend Andy's house and we're watching TV. And earlier in the night I'd gotten in a fight with my girlfriend, Jenny. You ever get in a fight with your girlfriend that's so bad that afterwards you don't know where you are or what year it is? I was just like, well, let's just watch Bagger Vance.
两年前我在洛杉矶，在朋友安迪家里看电视。那天晚上早些时候，我和女友珍妮吵了一架。你有没有和女友吵过那种严重的架，以至于事后你不知道自己在哪里，或者现在是哪一年？我当时就是觉得，好吧，还是看《重返荣耀》（Bagger Vance）吧。
She had been at the wedding of one of her friends. And she was annoyed because people she hardly knew kept asking about our status as a couple. So annoyed, that she called me to ask about our status as a couple. And this is problematic because I'd always been against the idea of marriage.
她去参加了她朋友的婚礼。她很烦，因为她几乎不认识的人一直在问我们的恋爱状态。她非常烦，以至于她打电话给我询问我们的恋爱状态。这很成问题，因为我一直反对婚姻这个想法。
I'd decided I wasn't going to get married until I was sure that nothing else good could happen in my life. Basically, I didn't see the upside of there being one person you're assigned to and who's assigned to you. Because I never looked at my parents' marriage, or really anyone who had been married 30 years and thought, "I gotta get me some of that."
我决定在确信我生活中不会再发生任何好事之前，我是不会结婚的。基本上，我不觉得和一个被指定给你、而你也被指定给他的人在一起有什么好处。因为我从未看过我父母的婚姻，或者任何结婚30年的人，然后想，“我也得弄一段那种婚姻。”
Well, this is something that Andy and I had rallied behind together. And we knew we were right. This is important for me to point out-- that sometimes when I think that I'm right, it can be a real source of contention between me and people who I'm close to. And the reason it's a source of contention, is that I'm right.
嗯，这是安迪和我一起坚持的立场。我们知道我们是对的。这一点很重要——有时当我认为自己正确时，这可能会成为我和亲近的人之间真正的争论源头。而成为争论源头的原因，是因为我确实是对的。
So not only did Andy and I not believe in marriage for ourselves, but we made it our mission to discourage other people from getting married, and people we cared about most. Andy and I stopped or put on hold four to seven marriages. We were pretty good. We weren't amazing, but we were solid.
所以，安迪和我不仅不相信婚姻适合我们自己，而且我们将阻止我们最关心的人结婚视为我们的使命。安迪和我阻止或搁置了四到七场婚礼。我们相当厉害。我们不算惊人，但我们很稳。
I'm at Andy's house and it's 1:00 AM, and I get into my rental car and I head back to my hotel. And I make a right turn out of Andy's street and I am T-boned. That's the culinary way of describing it. It means that I am hit, driver's side, at a 90-degree angle, like a T-bone steak. And it was by a drunk driver, who probably would have enjoyed that.
我在安迪家，当时是凌晨1点，我上了我的租车，开车回我的酒店。我从安迪那条街右转出来，然后我就被“T型撞击”了。这是描述这种情况的专业术语。意思是说，我在驾驶座一侧被以90度角撞击，就像T骨牛排一样。而且撞我的是一个醉酒司机，他可能还会享受那种感觉。
And being hit by a car is hard to describe. I'm sure some of you have experienced this, but you know those water slides where you lie on your back and then you fall at a vertical angle at like 1,000 miles an hour? It's like if you went on one of those, but no one told you you were going on the slide. It's like if you were taking a shower, and then you're on that slide.
被车撞是很难描述的。我相信你们中的一些人经历过，但你知道那种你躺在背上，然后以每小时1000英里的速度垂直掉落的水滑梯吗？这就好像你坐上了其中一个，但没人告诉你你要去滑滑梯。就像你正在洗澡，然后突然就上了那个滑梯。
So in one and a half seconds, my car spins around 180 degrees and I hear nothing. And I think I'm dead, there's no weight. I'm paralyzed. And then I hear nothing. And then I hear the other car skid out and drive away.
所以在一秒半的时间里，我的车旋转了180度，我什么都没听见。我以为我死了，没有重量感。我瘫痪了。然后我什么都没听见。然后我听到另一辆车加速逃离的声音。
And I have that Elie Wiesel moment where I think, "Human beings are animals." I think that's how he said it. And 20 minutes later, I'm sitting on the curb. Andy had shown up, as well the police and the paramedics, and that's when I start crying.
我有那种埃利·维塞尔（Elie Wiesel）式的时刻，我想，“人类是动物。”我想他是这么说的。20分钟后，我坐在路边。安迪出现了，警察和护理人员也到了，那时我开始哭。
You know how when you drop a baby on the ground? It doesn't start crying right away because it doesn't understand the concept of dropping a baby on the ground. Until it sees your face and then it's like, oh I guess I should be crying or something.
你知道当你把婴儿掉在地上的时候吗？它不会马上哭，因为它不理解把婴儿掉在地上的概念。直到它看到你的脸，然后它才会想，哦，我想我应该哭或者什么的。
And I am crying because I'm looking at my totaled car, and it hits me that in that moment I might have ceased to exist. A police officer walks over to me and he says, "What happened?"
我在哭，因为我看着我的报废车，那一刻我意识到我可能已经不复存在了。一名警察向我走来，他说：“发生了什么？”
And I say, "I was hit by this car and then I heard nothing and then I heard it skid out and drive away."
我说，“我被那辆车撞了，然后我什么都没听见，接着我就听到它加速开走了。”
And he says, "Well, he didn't get too far." He points to the intersection 100 yards away and the other car has made a right turn and driven into a small tree.
他说，“嗯，他没跑多远。”他指向100码外的十字路口，那辆车右转撞进了一棵小树里。
And I can't help but think, "That is karma, bitch." That is a hit and run, and hit.
我忍不住想，“这就是报应，混蛋。”这就是肇事逃逸，然后被抓。
I'm on the curb, and the cop asked me to sign a piece of paper and I say, "What's it for?"
我在路边，警察让我签一张纸，我说，“这是干什么的？”
And he says, "It's a statement saying you're OK and that we can leave."
他说，“这是一份声明，说你没事，我们可以离开了。”
And I said, "I don't know if I'm OK."
我说，“我不知道我是否有事。”
And he says, "Just sign it."
他说，“签了就是。”
And I said, "No, I actually-- I'm a little shaken up."
我说，“不，我其实——我有点受惊了。”
And he says, "Just sign it." And he holds it in my face, and it occurs to me that he's not going to move.
他说，“签了就是。”他把纸怼到我脸上，我意识到他不会让步。
And so I sign it. And Andy drives me to the hospital just as a precaution. And we had to wait an hour because the doctor is treating the drunk guy. He beat us there. Eventually we're with the doctor and he apologizes for the wait. And Andy says, "Was the other guy drunk?"
于是我签了。安迪开车送我去了医院，以防万一。我们等了一个小时，因为医生正在治疗那个醉汉。他比我们先到。最后我们见到了医生，他为等待道歉。安迪问，“那个人喝醉了吗？”
And the doctor says, "I can't answer that."
医生说，“我不能回答那个问题。”
And Andy says, "Was he?" He uses the tactic we had learned earlier from the cop. And it works!
安迪说，“他喝了吗？”他用了我们之前从警察那里学到的策略。这招管用！
The doctor says, "Well, he's heading to jail now." And Andy and I flash each other a look like the Hardy Boys. Case closed.
医生说，“嗯，他现在要进监狱了。”安迪和我交换了一个眼神，就像《哈迪兄弟》侦探一样。结案。
Andy and I get back to the house at 4 or 5 o'clock, and I have one of those cliche revelations a lot of people have when they have near death experiences. And I'm like, I think I have to call Jenny and tell her that we need to get married. And Andy says, "Sleep on it."
安迪和我在凌晨4点或5点回到家，我产生了许多人在濒死经历中常有的那种老套的顿悟。我想，我得打电话给珍妮，告诉她我们需要结婚。安迪说，“睡一觉再想吧。”
And I say, "No, no. I figured it out. I mean this all makes sense. I need to call her right now."
我说，“不，不。我想通了。我的意思是这一切都说得通。我得现在就给她打电话。”
And he says, "Mike, sleep on it." He saves me.
他说，“迈克，睡一觉再说吧。”他救了我。
And the next morning, I fly back to New York and I get a call on my voice mail from the rental car agency telling me that the accident report found me at fault. And I owed $12,000 for the repairs on the other guy's Mercedes SUV. And I called back right away, and I explained that this is a mistake and the woman says, "Unless they change the accident report, you owe $12,000."
第二天早上，我飞回纽约，在语音信箱里收到租车公司的电话，告诉我事故报告显示是我方的错。我欠了12000美元来修理那个家伙的梅赛德斯SUV。我马上打回去，解释说这是一个错误，但那个女人说，“除非他们修改事故报告，否则你得赔12000美元。”
And so I just start freaking out. And I'm like, I need to fix this. I get the accident report and it's a mess. I can see why there's a misunderstanding. An accident report is kind of like homework for cops. And Officer Timson, not so good with the homework. The report mixes up vehicle one and vehicle two, driver one and driver two. I actually want to show you this.
于是我开始崩溃。我心想，我得解决这个问题。我拿到了事故报告，简直一团糟。我能看出为什么会有误解。事故报告对警察来说就像家庭作业一样。而蒂姆森警官（Officer Timson），不太擅长做作业。报告把车辆一和车辆二、驾驶员一和驾驶员二混淆了。我真的很想给你们看看这个。
This is the actual report, and it mixes it up so badly that it says P-1, that's me, started to go, but all of a sudden V-1, that's also me, came at a high rate of speed, crashing into him. They're saying I crashed into my own car. I mean I'm pretty self-destructive, but I would never crash into my own car, with my own car. Nor would I understand how to do that.
这是真实的报告，它混淆得太离谱了，上面写着P-1，也就是我，开始行驶，但突然之间V-1，那也是我，以极高的速度冲过来，撞向了他。他们是说我撞了我自己的车。我的意思是，我很善于自我毁灭，但我绝不会用自己的车去撞自己的车。我也根本不明白该怎么做那种事。
I also love this. The statement of the other driver at the scene of the crime. I was going on Venice. I'm not too sure. I was going away from the beach. I was driving. I don't know what happened. Did I hurt anyone? I don't know where I was going, but I came from home. I had a sip of beer.
我也很喜欢这个。另一位驾驶员在犯罪现场的陈述。我当时在威尼斯大道上行驶。我不太确定。我当时正背离海滩行驶。我在开车。我不知道发生了什么。我伤害到谁了吗？我不知道我要去哪里，但我从家里来。我喝了一口啤酒。
Which is really everyone's favorite quantity of beer-- is the sip. That's what they serve at the pubs these days-- a pint, a pitcher, a sip, a tablespoon. People are like, aw man, I had a sip of beer. I don't know where I'm driving from, or where I'm driving to.
这真的是每个人最喜欢的啤酒量——一口。这就是现在酒吧里供应的量——一品脱、一大扎、一口、一汤匙。人们就像，噢伙计，我喝了一口啤酒。我不知道我是从哪里开过来的，也不知道我要开到哪里去。
Well, the problem is that even with all that, Officer Timson made one key mistake. He checked the box that said that I was at fault. So I called the police station to get the captain on the phone, and he ducks my calls for days. And I can't get in touch with him, and then finally I get him on the phone. And I'm so relieved. I'm like, I explained that I was wronged, I was nearly killed, and I tell him the whole story.
嗯，问题在于，尽管有这些，蒂姆森警官还是犯了一个关键错误。他勾选了说我有过错的方框。所以我打电话给警察局找队长，他躲了我好几天。我联系不上他，最后终于在电话里找到了他。我感到如释重负。我解释说我受到了冤枉，我差点丢了命，我把整个故事都告诉了他。
And he says, "You made a bad turn, now do the right thing, and pay for the guy's car. I know."
他说，“你转弯失误了，现在做正确的事，赔那家伙的车吧。我知道。”
And I explained like this is just an easy thing to fix. Its just a mix up. And he's not hearing any of it. And finally I'm like, please I mean can we just discuss this for a second like just as people, just as like one human being to another?
我解释说这其实很容易解决。这只是个混淆。但他根本听不进去。最后我说，求你了，我的意思是我们可以像普通人一样，像一个人对另一个人那样讨论一下这件事吗？
At this point I'd become Adam Sandler in one of his more sentimental films. I was like can you see how crazy this is? This guy who is drunk crashed into my car, he nearly killed me. I mean inches from where he hit I'd be dead, and you're saying that my parents would have had to pay for his car.
到了这个地步，我简直变成了亚当·桑德勒（Adam Sandler）在某部情感电影里的角色。我说，你能看出这有多疯狂吗？那个醉酒的人撞了我的车，他差点杀了我。我的意思是，如果他撞击的位置离我再近几英寸我就没命了，而你却说我父母必须赔他的车。
And he says, "Do the right thing, and pay for the guy's car."
他说，“做正确的事，赔那家伙的车。”
And I hang up the phone, and this is when it becomes about principle. This isn't about money. This is about stopping a man who has no regard for people or the law. This is China Town.
我挂断了电话，这时事情就变成了原则问题。这不是钱的问题。这是为了阻止一个不尊重人、不尊重法律的家伙。这就是《唐人街》（China Town）。
I start printing out Google maps of the scene of the accident and California state driving laws. I pore over the police report, circling inconsistencies, and scrolling notes in the margins. Like, are you kidding me? And this makes no sense and what is this blacked-out part? There was a blacked-out part next to his blood alcohol level. I'm calling lawyers and private investigators. There's only one lawyer who will even consider my case. He's an accident lawyer, and he says, "Did you have any loss of income from the accident?"
我开始打印事故现场的谷歌地图和加州交通法规。我仔细研读警察报告，圈出矛盾之处，在页边空白处写下笔记。就像，你在开玩笑吗？这一切都说不通，还有这个被涂黑的部分是什么？他血液酒精浓度旁边有一个被涂黑的部分。我开始打电话给律师和私人调查员。只有一个律师考虑接我的案子。他是一位事故律师，他说，“事故导致你收入损失了吗？”
I said, "No."
我说，“没有。”
And he says, "Did you have any loss of income-- from the accident?" And I say, "No, this isn't about money." And it gets very quiet.
他说，“那事故导致你——收入损失了吗？”我说，“没有，这不是钱的问题。”空气变得非常安静。
I said, "I shouldn't have to lie. I'm right."
我说，“我不应该撒谎。我是对的。”
And he doesn't take the case. And this is when I start going crazy. I start obsessing over the actual driver. I'm like, who is this man who nearly killed me and wants my $12,000? I know his name, it's Jim Bosworth.
他没接这个案子。这时我开始变得疯狂。我开始沉迷于那个驾驶员本身。我想，这个差点杀了我，又想要我12000美元的男人是谁？我知道他的名字，他叫吉姆·博斯沃思（Jim Bosworth）。
That's not his name, but I do know his name. And I register for an online account at netdetective.com, which is a great site for vigilantes who have $29.95. And so I know where he lives, what he does. My inner monologue becomes like a movie trailer for a revenge thriller like, "Jim Bosworth thought he was going to get away with this, but he didn't count on one thing-- Mike Birbiglia."
那不是他的真名，但我确实知道他的名字。我在netdetective.com注册了一个在线账户，对于有29.95美元的私刑执法者来说，这是一个很棒的网站。所以我知道了他的住处，他的职业。我的内心独白变得像一部复仇惊悚片的电影预告片，“吉姆·博斯沃思以为他能逃脱制裁，但他没算到一件事——迈克·比比利亚。”
So I'm up until 3:00 in the morning every night. It's hard when you know that you're right. And I start coming up with these illogical plans like, I'm going to quit my job and work on this full-time. I'm going to sue the LAPD. And I will track down Jim Bosworth.
所以我每天晚上熬到凌晨3点。当你明明知道自己是对的时候，这很难受。我开始想出一些不合逻辑的计划，比如，我要辞掉工作全职处理这件事。我要起诉洛杉矶警局。我要追踪到吉姆·博斯沃思。
At this point people stop talking to me. I mean my friends would call me and they'd be like, "Hey, what's going on?" I'd be like, "I'll tell you what's going on."
这时人们不再跟我说话了。我的朋友们会打电话给我，问，“嘿，最近怎么样？”我会说，“我告诉你发生了什么。”
They'd be like, "You should get a lawyer." And I snap. I'm like, "This is way past lawyers!"
他们会说，“你应该找个律师。”我突然爆发了。我说，“这早就过了找律师的阶段了！”
One night Jenny and I are out to dinner and she's talking, but I'm not listening because I'm writing down ideas I have about the case on my napkin. This is the actual napkin. I don't know if you can see this, but it's a very carefully laid-out argument about my situation.
一天晚上珍妮和我出去吃饭，她在说话，但我没在听，因为我在餐巾纸上写关于这个案子的想法。这就是那张真实的餐巾纸。我不知道你们能不能看清，但这是关于我情况的一个非常仔细的论点。
And she says, "Why don't you do that in the morning?"
她说，“为什么不早上做呢？”
And I say, "This is serious. Which part of this napkin don't you understand?"
我说，“这是严肃的。你哪一部分看不懂？”
She says, "I don't know what to tell you Mike because you're right, but it's only hurting you. And I'm just so glad that you're alive, and I think that we should focus on that."
她说，“我不知道该怎么跟你说，迈克，因为你是对的，但这只会伤害你自己。我只是很高兴你还活着，我认为我们应该关注这一点。”
She only has to say it once, and I dropped the case and I pay for the guy's car. And a few months later Jenny and I go to City Hall and get married.
她只需要说一次，我就放弃了案子，赔了那个人的车。几个月后，珍妮和我去市政厅结婚了。
I still didn't believe in the idea of marriage, and I still don't. But I believe in her, and I've given up on the idea of being right.
我仍然不相信婚姻的想法，现在也不信。但我相信她，我也放弃了非要争个对错的想法。
Mike Birbiglia. Mike Birbiglia's one man show, Sleepwalk With Me, is playing off Broadway. This fall, Mike Birbiglia is coming to your town on a 30-city tour.
迈克·比比利亚。迈克·比比利亚的单人秀《与我梦游》（Sleepwalk With Me）正在外百老汇上演。今年秋天，迈克·比比利亚将开启全国30个城市的巡演。
Coming up. The secret place that Dan Savage sneaks off to at 2 o'clock on Tuesday afternoon. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来。丹·萨维奇（Dan Savage）在周二下午2点偷偷溜去的秘密地方。请稍候，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Each week on our show we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show recorded at the Chicago Theater and at NYU's Skirball Center and broadcast to 430 movie theaters across the country, Return to the Scene of the Crime. We have various people returning to the scenes of various crimes, looking for clues and answers. It's very nice to see you all here in person versus the way that I usually encounter you, which is during the pledge drive, calling you each one by one to administer pledge drive justice. That was kind of an uneasy laugh, if you ask me.
每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，带来关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目在芝加哥剧院和纽约大学斯基博尔中心录制，并广播到全国430家电影院，主题是“重返犯罪现场”。我们有不同的人回到各种犯罪现场，寻找线索和答案。很高兴能在这里亲眼见到你们，而不是像往常那样通过捐赠活动，一个个给你们打电话，执行捐赠活动的公正。如果你们问我，刚才那个笑声有点勉强。
We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Return to the Scene of the Scene.
我们进入了节目的第二幕。重返现场的现场。
Joss Whedon is one of those people who either you have never heard of him at all, have no idea who he is, or you love him.
乔斯·韦登（Joss Whedon）属于那种要么你从没听说过他，根本不知道他是谁，要么就是你深爱着他的人。
The creator of the funny, iconic Buffy the Vampire Slayer, but also Angel, Firefly, Serenity, Doll House. He makes movies. This year, with some collaborators, he decided he was going to make a musical, not for television, not for the movies, but for the internet. And the result was this online musical called Doctor Horrible's Sing-Along Blog.
他是滑稽且标志性的《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》的创作者，也是《天使》、《萤火虫》、《冲出宁静号》、《玩偶特工》的创作者。他制作电影。今年，他和一些合作者决定制作一部音乐剧，不是为了电视，也不是为了电影，而是为了互联网。结果就是这部名为《恐怖博士的欢唱博客》（Doctor Horrible's Sing-Along Blog）的在线音乐剧。
For those of you in the seats looking at the people around you wondering, what are we talking about? Why are people so excited? The story of Doctor Horrible is-- he's played by Neil Patrick Harris-- and he's a wannabe, not terribly successful super villain. And this is from his video blog. The show is his video blog.
对于那些坐在座位上看着周围的人，纳闷着：我们在谈论什么？为什么人们这么兴奋？《恐怖博士》的故事是——由尼尔·帕特里克·哈里斯（Neil Patrick Harris）饰演——他是一个想成为、但不太成功的超级恶棍。这就是他的视频博客。这部剧就是他的视频博客。
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频回放]
-Emails.
-电子邮件。
-TooSlyForYou writes, "Hey, genius. " Wow, sarcasm. That's original.
-TooSlyForYou写道，“嘿，天才。”哇，讽刺。真有创意。
-"Where are the gold bars you were supposed to pull out of that bank vault with your trans-matter ray? Obviously it failed, or it would be in the papers."
-“你应该用你的物质转移射线从银行金库里拉出的金条在哪里？显然它失败了，否则报纸上早就登了。”
-Well, no they're not going to say anything in the press, but behold. Transported from there to here.
-嗯，不，他们不会在媒体上说什么，但瞧。从那里传送到这里。
Everybody listening on the radio, he's holding up a baggie full of brown liquid.
所有听广播的人，他举起了一个装满棕色液体的塑料袋。
-Molecules tend to shift during the trans-matter events.
-分子在物质转移事件中倾向于移动。
Dr. Horrible, in the first episode, he goes on from that point to explain this new invention that he's invented to rule the world that he's almost perfected called the Freeze Ray. He then goes through some other emails, another email or two, including one from a guy claiming to be his nemesis, to which Dr. Horrible replies, "Dude, you are not my nemesis."
在第一集中，恐怖博士从那里继续解释他发明的一种统治世界的新发明，他几乎已经完善了它，叫做冷冻射线。然后他浏览了其他电子邮件，还有一两封，包括一封来自自称是他宿敌的人的邮件，恐怖博士回复说，“哥们，你不是我的宿敌。”
And then, Dr. Horrible comes to this email.
然后，恐怖博士看到了这封邮件。
-Here's one from Dead Not Sleeping. "Longtime watcher, first time writing." Blah blah blah blah. "You always say in your blog that you will show her the way. Show her you are a true villain. Who is her, and does she even know that your--
-这里有一封来自Dead Not Sleeping的邮件。“长期关注者，第一次写信。”巴拉巴拉。“你在博客里总说你会为她指引方向。展示你是真正的恶棍。她是谁，她甚至知道你的——
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频结束]
Dr. Horrible. So anyway they did this on the internet and it's a crazy, huge sensation. 200,000 people an hour tried to download it on the first day. It won a People's Choice Award for Favorite Online Sensation, which I think is a really funny category. This year it's been one of the top 25 best-selling movies and TV shows at Amazon.com and so like, big sensation right? So they decided let's put out a DVD. Of course, that would mean that they would have to return to the scene of their own work and do a DVD commentary. And so in an incredibly macho move, they decided OK, well we have this musical we made. They would also do the DVD commentary-- as a musical.
恐怖博士。所以无论如何，他们把这个放在网上，这成了一个疯狂的、巨大的轰动。第一天每小时有20万人试图下载。它获得了人民选择奖的“最受喜爱在线轰动奖”，我认为这是一个非常有趣的类别。今年它已成为Amazon.com上最畅销的25部电影和电视节目之一，所以，巨大的轰动，对吧？所以他们决定，出个DVD吧。当然，这意味着他们必须回到自己作品的现场，做一份DVD评论。于是，在一场极其大男子主义的举动中，他们决定，好吧，既然我们做了这部音乐剧。他们也要做DVD评论——以音乐剧的形式。
So the commentary itself also rhymes, it's set to music. It both comments on, and critiques, the conventions of a DVD commentary, while synchronously existing with the movie. So it included this song where Joss Whedon got to express, as a filmmaker, what it feels like, what it means to do a DVD commentary, and have to return to his own work and talk about that work as part of his job. And he's agreed to play that song for us here today.
所以评论本身也押韵，也是配乐的。它既评论和批判了DVD评论的惯例，又与电影同步存在。所以它包括了这首歌，乔斯·韦登作为一名电影制作人，表达了做DVD评论的感觉，意味着什么，以及不得不回到自己的作品现场并谈论那部作品作为他工作的一部分。他同意今天在这里为我们演唱这首歌。
Before we booked him for this show, he actually never had played in front of an audience larger than nine people. He actually taught himself piano to write musicals like this a couple years ago. He never had performed on a stage. He'll be accompanied-- he wanted an actual professional musician with him just for backup-- so he'll be accompanied on guitar by Matt Clark who is a longtime Chicago musician to a lot of bands, most recently White Light.
在我们邀请他参加这个节目之前，他实际上从未在超过九人的观众面前表演过。他几年前为了写这样的音乐剧，自学了钢琴。他从未在舞台上表演过。他将伴奏——他想找一位真正的专业音乐家陪同作为后盾——所以他将由马特·克拉克（Matt Clark）在吉他上伴奏，马特是一位长期的芝加哥音乐家，参与过许多乐队，最近的是White Light乐队。
Please welcome in his very brave musical, theatrical debut, film-making legend, Mr. Joss Whedon.
欢迎他在音乐和戏剧界的勇敢首秀，电影制作传奇，乔斯·韦登先生。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
[MUSIC - "HEART (BROKEN)" BY JOSS WHEDON]
[音乐 - "心脏（破碎）" 作者：乔斯·韦登]
A caveman painted on a cave.
穴居人在洞穴上作画。
It was a bison, was a fave
那是一头野牛，是心头好。
The other cave people would rave.
其他穴居人会赞叹不已。
They didn't ask why?
他们没问为什么？
Why paint a bison if it's dead?
如果野牛已经死了，为什么还要画它？
When did you choose the color red?
你什么时候选的红色？
What was the process in your head?
你脑子里的创作过程是什么？
He told their story.
他讲述了他们的故事。
What came before he didn't show.
在此之前发生了什么他没展示。
We're not supposed to.
我们不应该展示。
In Homer's Odyssey was swell,
荷马的《奥德赛》很棒。
A bunch of guys that went through hell.
一伙人经历地狱。
He told the tale, but didn't tell the audience why.
他讲了故事，但没告诉观众为什么。
He didn't say, here's what it means,
他没说，这就是它的意思。
And here's a few deleted scenes.
这是几个删减片段。
Charybdis tested well with teens,
卡律布狄斯在青少年观众中反响很好。
He's not the story.
他不是故事的一部分。
He's just a door we open if our lives need lifting.
他只是我们需要振奋生活时打开的一扇门。
But now we pick, pick, pick, pick, pick it apart.
但现在我们挑选、挑选、挑选、挑选、挑选它。
Open it up to find the tick, tick, tick of a heart.
剖开它以寻找心脏滴答、滴答、滴答的声音。
A heart broken.
一颗破碎的心。
It's broken by the endless loads
被无尽的负荷压垮了。
Of making ofs and mobisodes,
制作花絮和手机剧，
The tie-ins, prequels, games, and codes the audience buys.
周边、前传、游戏和代码，观众都在买。
The narrative dies, stretched and torn.
叙事死了，被拉伸和撕裂。
Hey spoiler warnin'.
嘿，剧透警告。
We're gonna pick, pick, pick, pick, pick it apart.
我们还要挑选、挑选、挑选、挑选、挑选它。
Open it up to find the tick, tick tick of a heart.
剖开它以寻找心脏滴答、滴答、滴答的声音。
A heart broken down.
一颗破碎的心。
Do you really need to know?
你真的需要知道吗？
Sit back, relax, enjoy the show, oh no.
坐下来，放松，享受节目，哦不。
Let it go, oh no.
随它去吧，哦不。
No the crowd won't rest 'til he explains,
不，直到他解释清楚，观众不会罢休，
Like zombies clawing for his brains,
就像僵尸抓挠他的大脑，
Or anything that infotains
或者任何娱乐资讯，
And that maintains my fame,
这维持了我的名声，
My fame, my precious quasi-fame.
我的名声，我宝贵的准名声。
What am I doing? There's people watching.
我在干什么？有人在看呢。
I sang some things I didn't mean.
我唱了一些我没想表达的东西。
I think this commentary's keen.
我想这评论很机智。
So let's return now to the scene. I'll tell the story.
所以现在让我们回到现场。我来把故事讲完。
This song itself was hard to write.
这首歌本身很难写。
I cut the bridge to keep it tight.
我砍掉了副歌来保持紧凑。
It's kind of slow and doesn't quite advance the story.
它有点慢，而且并不能推进故事。
It's really boring. That's all done.
真的很无聊。都完成了。
Get on the fun train.
登上快乐列车吧。
We're gonna pick, pick, pick, pick, pick it apart.
我们还要挑选、挑选、挑选、挑选、挑选它。
Open it up to  find the tick, tick, tick of a heart.
剖开它以寻找心脏滴答、滴答、滴答的声音。
We're gonna pick, we're gonna pick, pick, pick it apart,
我们还要挑选，我们还要挑选、挑选、挑选它。
Pick up a stick and find the tick, tick, tick of a heart.
拿起棍子寻找心脏滴答、滴答、滴答的声音。
A heart on sale now.
一颗正在促销的心。
Mr. Joss Whedon. On vocals and piano. Matt Clark on guitar. Matt, by the way, is now a law student at Washington University in Saint Louis and is skipping out of finals to be here. Good luck to him.
乔斯·韦登先生。主唱兼钢琴。马特·克拉克吉他伴奏。顺便说一句，马特现在是圣路易斯华盛顿大学的法学院学生，为了在这里演出正逃掉期末考试。祝他好运。
We've arrived at Act Three of our show.
我们到达了节目的第三幕。
Act Three. Our Man of Perpetual Sorrow
第三幕。我的忧伤之人
One of the things that's the strangest thing about returns to the scene of the crime are that so many of them involve somebody returning to someplace where he really doesn't want to go. Someplace that he dislikes, or disagrees with, or wished he'd never been at in the first place. But then the person finds they can't help themselves, he goes back.
关于重返犯罪现场最奇怪的事情之一是，其中很多人都涉及某人回到他根本不想去的地方。他不喜欢、不同意或希望自己从一开始就没去过的地方。但随后那个人发现他无法自拔，他还是回去了。
Well, Dan Savage has written books about he and his boyfriend deciding to get married and then adopting a little boy, actually not in that order. He made a name for himself writing a funny and deeply informed sex advice column called Savage Love. Please welcome Dan Savage.
嗯，丹·萨维奇写过关于他和男友决定结婚然后收养一个小男孩的书，其实顺序不是那样的。他通过撰写一篇有趣且内涵深刻的性建议专栏“萨维奇之爱”（Savage Love）而声名鹊起。欢迎丹·萨维奇。
Hello. This is intimidating with that kind of welcome.
你好。这样的欢迎太令人受宠若惊了。
The crime scene in this story is a Catholic church. In particular, Saint Ignatius on Glenwood Avenue on the North Side of Chicago. And yes, I went to Catholic grade schools. And yes, I was an altar boy. But no, the crime is not what you've already assumed. No Catholic school children were harmed during the production of this story. So you can relax.
这个故事里的犯罪现场是一座天主教堂。具体来说，是芝加哥北区格伦伍德大道上的圣依纳爵教堂（Saint Ignatius）。是的，我上过天主教小学。是的，我是辅祭。但不是，罪行不是你们已经假设的那样。这部故事的制作过程中没有任何天主教学校的学生受到伤害。所以你们可以放心了。
I'm not a practicing Catholic. I am a lapsed Catholic. An agnostatheist. A sort of agnostic-atheist hybrid. Which means I cross myself on airplanes. I once blew up at a friend who thought it was hilarious to invert one of the crucifixes in my ironic collection of Catholic kitsch. And half the time when I take the Lord's name in vain, like when I mutter Jesus Christ through clenched teeth as my boyfriend passes someone going 90 miles an hour, I am in all honesty seeking the protection of a higher power.
我不是一个虔诚的天主教徒。我是一个“流失”的天主教徒。一个不可知-无神论者。一种不可知论和无神论的混合体。这意味着我在飞机上会画十字。我曾经对一个觉得把我的铁质天主教小摆设收藏中的十字架倒过来很有趣的朋友发火。当我有意或无意提起上帝的名字时，比如当我男友以每小时90英里的速度超车时，我从牙缝里嘟囔着“耶稣基督”，我真心实意地是在寻求更高力量的庇护。
I go right back to not believing in God once he's safely delivered us back to the right hand lane. Which makes me a hypocrite. And an ingrate. I was raised in a Catholic home. I went to the same Catholic grade school my mother and grandmother did, and I had some of the same nuns they both did as teachers.
一旦他安全地把我们送到正确的车道，我就会立刻回到不相信上帝的状态。这让我成了一个伪君子。一个忘恩负义的人。我是在一个天主教家庭长大的。我上了和我母亲、祖母同一所天主教小学，我还有一些和她们一样的修女老师。
But by age seven, I was already having trouble reconciling loving father with eternal damnation. But the fatal blow came at age 14, with the realization that I was gay. Something I figured out at roughly the same time I entered an all-male high school for Catholic boys thinking about becoming priests. Which is a bit like realizing you're an alcoholic on your first day working at the Budweiser bottling plant.
但在七岁时，我就已经在调和“仁慈的父亲”与“永恒的诅咒”方面遇到困难了。但致命一击是在14岁时，我意识到自己是同性恋。我意识到这一点的时间大约和我进入一所全是天主教男孩、考虑成为神父的高中是同一时间。这有点像你在百威啤酒灌装厂上班的第一天发现自己是个酒鬼。
Luckily for my sanity, I didn't think, "Oh my God, I'm going to hell." I thought, that can't be right. What the church-- my church-- says about me. They have to be wrong. Soon I was contemplating the possibility that the church was wrong about other stuff. Maybe lots of other stuff. The odds of virgin births. The virtues of celibacy. The evils of masturbation. And it didn't take long to arrive at the biggest doubt of all-- the existence of God. And that was that.
幸运的是，对于我的理智来说，我没有想，“噢，上帝，我要下地狱了。”我想的是，这肯定不对。我的教会——我的教堂——对我所说的话。他们肯定是错的。不久我就在思考，教会对其他事情也可能是错的。也许是很多其他事情。童贞生子的可能性。独身的美德。自慰的罪恶。而我也没花多久就得出了最大的怀疑——上帝是否存在。就是这样。
By senior year I'd started going to a public school and stopped going to church, except for the odd family wedding, baptism, or funeral. And they are all odd, aren't they? I go to church about as often as I go to Planned Parenthood for a Pap smear. Then, 12 months ago, my mother died. A virus can lay dormant in your body for so long that it's possible to forget you were ever infected. Then something happens that weakens your immune system and the virus seizes its opportunity. For more than two decades the Catholicism I'd contracted at Saint Ignatius had lain dormant, manifesting itself only on airplanes and in passing lanes. But the immunity I'd long enjoyed was weakened by my mother's death. Because since that sunny, awful day in Tucson last spring, I found myself slipping into Catholic churches.
高年级时我开始去公立学校，不再去教堂，除了偶尔的家庭婚礼、洗礼或葬礼。它们都很奇怪，不是吗？我去教堂的次数和我去计划生育诊所做巴氏涂片检查的次数差不多。然后，12个月前，我母亲去世了。病毒可以在你的体内潜伏很久，以至于你可能忘记自己曾经感染过。然后发生了一些削弱你免疫系统的事情，病毒就趁虚而入。二十多年来，我在圣依纳爵教堂感染的天主教信仰一直处于休眠状态，只在飞机上和超车道上表现出来。但我长期享受的免疫力因母亲的去世而减弱了。因为自从去年春天图森那个阳光明媚、糟糕透顶的日子以来，我发现自己开始溜进天主教堂。
Not for odd weddings or funerals, but on totally random days of non-holy, non-obligation. Tuesday afternoons, Friday mornings. And not just going to church, but going out of my way to go to church. There's a Modernist Catholic chapel close to my office. It won a big design award, but to me it looks like all modern churches do. Like someone stuck a crucifix up on the wall in the rec room at the Brady house.
不是为了奇怪的婚礼或葬礼，而是在完全随机的、非神圣、非义务的日子里。周二下午，周五上午。而且不仅仅是去教堂，而是专门绕道去教堂。我办公室附近有一座现代主义天主教堂。它赢过大设计奖，但在我看来，它看起来像所有的现代教堂一样。就像有人在布雷迪家（Brady house）活动室的墙上贴了一个十字架。
Saint James Cathedral in downtown Seattle, a longer walk, looks like a Catholic church should. A lot like Saint Ignatius, actually. Stained glass, marble, crowds of plaster saints. Saint James is open for contemplation all day during the week. There are usually one or two volunteers straightening up the hymnals and the offering envelopes in the backs of the pews, and keeping an eye on the homeless people, and me, that have come in to get out of the rain. There's no music, only a few lights are on, and when a priest strolls through he doesn't make eye contact with anyone.
西雅图市中心的圣雅各布大教堂（Saint James Cathedral），路程更远，看起来像一座天主教堂应该有的样子。其实很像圣依纳爵教堂。彩色玻璃、大理石、成群的石膏圣徒。圣雅各布大教堂整周都在开放供沉思。通常有一两个志愿者在整理长椅后面的赞美诗集和捐款信封，并留意着那些进来躲雨的无家可归者，还有我。没有音乐，只有几盏灯亮着，当神父走过时，他不与任何人眼神接触。
When my mother would call me with bad news-- a relative I hadn't seen in years diagnosed with cancer, a friend of hers with a desperately ill grandchild-- she would always say, "I know you don't pray, Daniel. Keep them in your thoughts." My mom knew that thoughts were the best I could do. And now, at Saint James, I sit in a bank of pews opposite a white marble statue of the Virgin Mother, stare into her face, and keep my mother in my thoughts. Sorry.
每当我母亲带着坏消息打电话给我——一个我多年未见的亲戚被诊断出癌症，或者她朋友的一个孙子病得很重——她总是说，“我知道你不祷告，丹尼尔。把他们放在你的心上。”我妈妈知道“思念”是我能做的最好的事。现在，在圣雅各布大教堂，我坐在长椅上，对面是圣母玛利亚的白色大理石雕像，凝视着她的脸，把母亲放在我的心里。对不起。
By her own estimation my mother was a good Catholic. She believed in Jesus, the Resurrection, the virgin births, both of them. There are two, did you know that? What are the odds? The Trinity, the Sacraments. She believed that sex was sacred, and that people, particularly people with children, should be married to each other. But she didn't believe that being a good Catholic meant blind obedience. So I guess you could say she was a good American Catholic. She believed women should be priests. That priests should be able to marry. And after four pregnancies in four years, she concluded that birth control was not a sin.
按照她自己的说法，我母亲是一个好天主教徒。她相信耶稣，复活，童贞生子，而且是两次。有两个，你知道吗？几率是多少？三位一体，圣礼。她相信性是神圣的，人们，特别是有孩子的人，应该彼此结婚。但她不认为做一个好天主教徒就意味着盲目服从。所以我猜你可以说她是一个典型的美国天主教徒。她相信女性应该成为神父。神父应该可以结婚。在四年内经历了四次怀孕后，她断定节育不是罪。
She prayed that the leaders of her church would come around during her lifetime. Unfortunately, the church, under the last two popes, went in the opposite direction. And whenever the present pope, Benny, she called him, or the previous pope, JP2, condemned birth control, or insisted that women could not and would not ever be ordained as priests, my mother would sometimes call me and sigh and say, it's like they're trying to make Lutherans of us all.
她祈祷教会领导人在她有生之年能改变主意。不幸的是，在过去两任教皇的领导下，教会走向了相反的方向。每当现任教皇，她称之为“本尼”（Benny），或者前任教皇JP2谴责节育，或者坚持认为女性不能也不会被任命为神父时，我母亲有时会打电话给我，叹气说，就像他们试图把我们都变成路德教徒一样。
But she refused to leave the church because she believed it was her church, too, just as much as it was Benny's, or JP2's. A little voice inside her head said, that can't be right, they must be wrong. That voice, the same one I heard, somehow left her faith stronger. She took it hard when I came out. Her first impulse was to call a priest. God bless Father Tom, who, when my mother, distraught, told him I'd just come out to her, placed a hand on my mother's knee and came out to her himself.
但她拒绝离开教会，因为她相信这也是她的教堂，和本尼的或JP2的一样多。她脑子里有一个小声音说，那肯定是不对的，他们一定是错的。那个声音，我听到的那个声音，反而使她的信仰更加坚定。我出柜时她很难过。她的第一反应是打电话给神父。上帝保佑汤姆神父，当母亲苦恼地告诉他我刚向她出柜时，他把手放在我母亲的膝盖上，向她坦白他自己也是同性恋。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
My mother came around fast. And came out swinging. Rainbow stickers on her car, a PFLAG membership, and an ultimatum delivered to the entire extended family. Anyone who had a problem with me, had a much bigger problem with her.
我母亲很快就想通了。而且开始反击。她的车上贴着彩虹贴纸，加入了PFLAG（同性恋亲友会），并向整个大家庭下了最后通牒。任何对我有意见的人，都会跟她有更大的意见。
My mother was diagnosed with a degenerative lung condition six years ago. She had some bad years, but she was stable enough last spring to drive down to the Southwest with her husband, my step dad, to visit her sisters. She took a turn in Tucson, where she was hospitalized for a week. But we thought she was going to pull through, as she had on several other occasions. Her doctors in Chicago had just given her two more years.
我母亲六年前被诊断出患有退行性肺部疾病。她经历了几年糟糕的日子，但去年春天病情稳定，足以和她的丈夫、我的继父一起开车去西南部看望她的姐妹们。她在图森病情恶化，在那里住了一周医院。但我们以为她能挺过来，就像她过去几次一样。她在芝加哥的医生刚给了她两年时间。
But the morning of her seventh day in the ICU, the morning we'd begun to make arrangements to get her back home to her own bed and her own doctors, a moment after my stepfather left her bedside for the first time in a week, a doctor appeared at the door of her room and waved me into the hallway. There'd been developments. Her lungs have been slowly disintegrating for five years, and now they were coming apart. One had a hole in it that was getting bigger, and there was no going home. This was it. The doctor told me he needed a medical directive from my mother, and he needed it now. Can I go get my stepfather? No. Now.
但在ICU的第七天早上，在我们开始安排她回家回到自己的床上看自己的医生时，继父一周来第一次离开床边，一位医生出现在门口，向我招手示意我到走廊去。情况发生了变化。她的肺部五年来一直在缓慢崩解，现在正在分崩离析。其中一个肺有一个洞，而且越来越大，她已经回不去家了。就是现在了。医生告诉我他需要我母亲的医疗指令，而且现在就要。我可以去叫我的继父吗？不。现在。
So it fell to me to tell my mother that she was going to die, and lay out her limited options. She could have a tube put down her throat and be hooked up to a machine that would breathe for her for a day or two. But she would be in a drug-induced coma, although she would live long enough for her other two sons to come to Tucson, but she wouldn't know that they were there. She could wear an oxygen mask that violently forced air into her lungs and live for six more hours. Or she could take the mask off and go now.
所以告诉母亲她要死了并说明她有限的选择，落在了我头上。她可以插管，连上一台机器呼吸一两天。但她会处于药物诱导的昏迷中，虽然她能活到她的另外两个儿子来到图森，但她不会知道他们在场。她可以戴上强迫空气进入肺部的氧气面罩，再活六个小时。或者她可以摘下面罩，现在就走。
No mask, she said. No tube. Now. I told the doctor. And then I ran to the ICU's waiting room to get my step dad and my sister and my aunt. She didn't go into the hospital expecting to die, and she was not ready to go.
不戴面罩，她说。不插管。现在。我告诉了医生。然后我跑向ICU的等候室去叫我的继父、姐妹和姨妈。她没想过进医院会死，她也没准备好离开。
When we were all at her bedside, she arched one eyebrow, shook her head and said, "Shit!"
当我们都站在床边时，她挑起一根眉毛，摇了摇头说，“Shit（该死）！”
My mother used profanity sparingly, and only in quotation marks. When she said "shit," what she meant was the kind of person who casually uses profanity might be inclined to say "shit" at a moment like this, but I am not the kind of person who uses profanity. I am a Catholic grandmother. And I certainly wouldn't use it at a moment like this, but if I were the kind of person who used profanity, "shit" might be the word I would use right now. But I'm not that kind of person. She swore on her death bed as a joke, because she wanted to make us feel better.
我母亲很少使用亵渎语言，而且只在引用时使用。当她说“shit”时，她的意思是，那种随便使用亵渎语言的人可能会在这个时候说“shit”，但我不是那种使用亵渎语言的人。我是一个天主教祖母。我绝对不会在这个时候使用它，但如果我是那种使用亵渎语言的人，“shit”可能就是我现在会用的词。但我不是那种人。她在临终前开玩笑地咒骂，因为她想让我们感觉好受点。
A priest arrived to perform last rites. And it helped her brace for what she knew was coming for an extremely painful final few moments. I could see it help. I could see the comfort the sacrament gave her. It gave me comfort. The priest led us in prayer. Prayers my mother and I both learned at Saint Ignatius. Prayers that filled a terrible silence, and solemnized an awful moment. And then my mother told us she would be with us always, looking down on us, and that we would see her again. She didn't say in heaven, but that is what she meant.
一位神父赶来做临终圣事。这帮助她坚强起来，迎接她知道即将来临的极其痛苦的最后几分钟。我能看到这很有帮助。我能看到圣礼给她带来的安慰。它也给了我安慰。神父带领我们祈祷。我和母亲在圣依纳爵教堂学会的祈祷。这些祈祷填补了可怕的沉默，并使这个可怕的时刻变得庄重。然后母亲告诉我们她会永远和我们在一起，注视着我们，我们还会再见到她。她没说在天堂，但那是她的意思。
Then she made her last request. "Remember me. Keep me in your thoughts, Daniel."
然后她提出了最后一个要求。“记住我。把我放在心里，丹尼尔。”
One of the cards in the back of the pews at Saint James is addressed to non-practicing Catholics. "WELCOME BACK" is printed in large letters across the top. Are you a Catholic who's been away from the church? Welcome back classes are designed to help you return to the sacraments and regular church attendance. A return to the sacraments.
圣雅各布大教堂长椅后的卡片之一是写给“非虔诚天主教徒”的。“欢迎回来”几个大字印在顶部。你是离开教会的天主教徒吗？“欢迎回来”课程旨在帮助你重返圣礼和常规礼拜。重返圣礼。
I fantasized about returning to the sacrament of confession. Forgive me father, for I have sinned. It's been 29 years since my last confession. Hope you packed a lunch.
我幻想过重返忏悔圣礼。宽恕我，神父，因为我犯了罪。距离我上次忏悔已经29年了。希望你准备好午餐了。
I want for there to be heaven. And I want her to be looking down on me. Though, and I say this is a professional sex advice columnist, not all the time. There are things a mother has a right not to know, she used to say. But Catholicism now tempts me. I wouldn't be wasting so much time in Saint James if it didn't. My boyfriend would not have found a "WELCOME BACK" card in the back pocket of my jeans if it didn't.
我希望有天堂。我希望她在注视着我。虽然，我是以一名专业性建议专栏作家的身份这么说，而不是一直看着。她过去常说，有些事情母亲有权不知道。但天主教现在诱惑着我。如果不是这样，我就不会在圣雅各布大教堂浪费这么多时间了。如果不是这样，我的男友就不会在我牛仔裤的后口袋里发现一张“欢迎回来”的卡片了。
But when I am tempted, when I feel like, maybe, I could go through the motions, Return to the sacraments, take what comfort I can, the Pope goes to Africa and says that condoms spread AIDS, or an archbishop in Brazil excommunicates a Catholic woman for getting her nine year old daughter an abortion, but not the Catholic man that raped the nine year old girl.
但当我受到诱惑时，当我感觉，也许，我可以走走过场，重返圣礼，获得我可以获得的安慰时，教皇去了非洲说避孕套传播艾滋病，或者巴西的一位大主教因一名天主教女性为她9岁的女儿堕胎而将她逐出教会，却并没有那样对待强奸那9岁女孩的天主教男子。
Or I contemplate how the church views me and the two people I love most in the world, my boyfriend of 14 years and our 11-year-old son, and I think, I can't even fake this. But there I sit at Saint James two or three times a week.
或者我想到教会是如何看待我和我生命中最爱的两个人——我相处14年的男友和我们11岁的儿子——我就想，我甚至连假装都做不到。但我还是每周两三次坐在圣雅各布大教堂。
Being brought up in a faith built around a guy jumping out of his tomb? That makes it difficult to reconcile oneself to the permanence of death. Who knew? The afterlife. It's cruel really, when you think about it. Criminal. Telling children that the people they love don't die. That there's some other life, some better place, a place without pulmonary fibrosis, or Tucson, Arizona.
在这样一个围绕着一个跳出坟墓的家伙的信仰中长大？这使得人们很难接受死亡的永久性。谁知道呢？来世。当你想到它时，这真的很残酷。犯罪。告诉孩子们他们爱的人不会死。告诉他们还有另一种生活，一个更好的地方，一个没有肺纤维化、没有图森、亚利桑那州的地方。
And maybe that lie is a comfort for some, but it's made death more painful for me, not less. Which is the opposite of religion's intended effect, is it not? The voice of unreason in my head, the voice of nuns back at Saint Ignatius says, "She lives. She is in heaven." And the voice of reason, which sounds a lot like Christopher Hitchens, barks back, "No, she doesn't. She's dead. Get over it already."
也许那个谎言对某些人来说是一种安慰，但它让我对死亡感到更加痛苦，而不是更少。这难道不是宗教预期效果的反面吗？我脑子里的非理性声音，圣依纳爵教堂修女的声音说，“她活着。她在天堂。”而理性声音，听起来很像克里斯托弗·希钦斯（Christopher Hitchens），反驳道，“不，她没有。她死了。快点走出来吧。”
This inability to reconcile myself to death has not been good for me. I visit Saint James like an addict drops by a crack house. For a fix. To deaden the pain, by losing myself momentarily in the fantasy that she lives, and that we will be together again. There's an inscription on the ceiling of Saint James, "I am in your midst."
这种无法调和死亡的心态对我来说并不好。我访问圣雅各布大教堂就像吸毒者访问毒窟一样。为了寻找慰藉。通过迷失在“她活着，我们会再次在一起”的幻想中，来减轻痛苦。圣雅各布大教堂的天花板上有一段铭文，“我在你们中间。”
If I were the kind of person who could believe, I would believe. But I'm not that kind of person. Shit. Thank you.
如果我是那种能相信的人，我就会相信。但我不是那种人。Shit。谢谢。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Dan Savage. Sex advice columnist. Editor of The Stranger. And the host of one of the most entertaining podcasts in the country, The Savage Love podcast.
丹·萨维奇。性建议专栏作家。《The Stranger》编辑。以及全国最有趣的播客之一，“萨维奇之爱”播客的主持人。
A couple weeks ago as we were preparing for today's broadcast, I was in Baltimore visiting my dad, and I'd been going over drafts of the stories for today's show including Dan's, and I was visiting my dad in Baltimore. And my dad showed me how he had digitized all of our old family videos, which apparently is a really good project if you're retired.
几周前当我们准备今天的广播时，我在巴尔的摩看望我爸爸，我一直在审阅今天节目故事的草稿，包括丹的故事，我当时在巴尔的摩看望我父亲。我父亲向我展示了他如何将我们所有的老家庭录像数字化，这显然是一个退休后的好项目。
And among the videos was footage from one of our very first live shows. We'd just barely been on the air at all, and it was Valentine's Day in 1998. It was a slightly smaller audience than we have today. It was at a bar. The Empty Bottle on Western in Chicago. The Empty Bottle's reach is that big? Anyway so he had footage. He had filmed the thing, and there was this footage that I didn't even know existed, and had never seen.
录像中包括我们最早的现场表演之一的片段。我们几乎刚开播，那是1998年的情人节。观众比今天少一点。那是在一个酒吧。芝加哥西部大道上的Empty Bottle。“Empty Bottle”的影响力有那么大吗？总之他有录像。他拍了这个东西，有这个片段，我甚至不知道它存在，也从未见过。
And onstage was me and my mom. My mom died five years ago. She was a marriage therapist and she was giving Valentine's Day relationship advice. And on stage with her was Dan Savage who was giving relationship and sex advice. And then at some point, Dan introduces a guest of his own. Let's roll that.
台上是我和我妈。我妈五年前去世了。她是一位婚姻治疗师，她在给情人节关系建议。和她一起在台上的是丹·萨维奇，他正在提供关系和性建议。然后在某个时候，丹介绍了他的嘉宾。让我们播放那一段。
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[视频回放]
-Judy Savage Sobiesk everybody.
-朱迪·萨维奇·索比斯克（Judy Savage Sobiesk），大家欢迎。
-Mrs. Savage I want you to just help out by reading some questions with me, so why don't you start with that one, because--
-萨维奇太太，我想请你帮帮忙，和我一起读一些问题，所以为什么不从那个开始，因为——
-Thank God for trifocals. Why are men typically aroused more by seeing naked bodies and women are typically more aroused by reading about them?
-感谢上帝赐予三光眼镜。为什么男人通常看到裸体更能激起性欲，而女性通常阅读相关内容更能激起性欲？
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[视频结束]
Right, Yeah, this is the main thing I learned watching this, is that Dan and I made our moms take part in a show that was really, really dirty.
没错，是的，我从观看这段视频中学到的主要东西是，丹和我让我们的妈妈参与了一个真的、真的很脏的节目。
Well, our program is produced today by our Senior Producer, Julie Snyder, our Production Manager, Seth Lind, and me. With Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Keonig, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Production help from Andy Dixon. Music help from Jessica Hopper. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Recording by Sarah Toulouse and Mary Gaffney. Station outreach by Melissa Barkley at Public Radio International. Executive Producers for our cinema event Julie and Robert Borchard-Young. Directed by David Stern.
好吧，我们今天的节目由我们的高级制片人朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）、制作经理塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）和我制作。还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Keonig）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。制作帮助来自安迪·迪克森（Andy Dixon）。音乐帮助来自杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨（Adrianne Mathiowetz）负责我们的网站。莎拉·图卢兹（Sarah Toulouse）和玛丽·加夫尼（Mary Gaffney）负责录音。国际公共广播电台的梅丽莎·巴克利（Melissa Barkley）负责电台外联。我们的电影活动的执行制片人是朱莉和罗伯特·博查德-杨（Robert Borchard-Young）。导演是大卫·斯特恩（David Stern）。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
If you're listening to the radio and you want to see the full 90-minute show that we did in movie theaters, we're going to rebroadcast today's cinema event in movie theaters May 7.
如果你正在收听广播，想要看到我们在电影院制作的完整90分钟节目，我们将在5月7日在电影院重播今天的电影活动。
Thanks to Vicki Weaver, the head of probation for Putnam County Court. Seth Barrish [UNINTELLIGIBLE], Josh Noel, my dad Barry Glass for video dubs, Brent [? Candley ?] and Nicom Communications and Paula [? Pevzner. ?] Thanks to Chicago homicide detectives Luis Munoz and Mark Czworniak. Music for our live show provided by the band Chin Chin, [? Von ?] [? Pitino, ?] Cliff Goldmacher, Kevin Hayes, Darren Wayne, K-Crews, and Fun Factor
感谢普特南县法院缓刑部主管维基·韦弗（Vicki Weaver）。塞斯·巴里什，乔什·诺埃尔，我的父亲巴里·格拉斯的视频配音，布伦特·坎德利和Nicom通讯公司，以及保拉·佩夫兹纳。感谢芝加哥凶杀案侦探路易斯·穆尼奥斯（Luis Munoz）和马克·茨沃尼亚克（Mark Czworniak）。我们现场表演的音乐由Chin Chin乐队、冯·皮蒂诺、克里夫·戈德马赫（Cliff Goldmacher）、凯文·海耶斯（Kevin Hayes）、达伦·韦恩（Darren Wayne）、K-Crews和Fun Factor提供。
For everybody listening on the radio, our live cinema event included an incredibly sad and beautiful animated cartoon by Chris Ware. You can watch that online. You can also see an extra video that we made. David Rakoff, Dave Hill, Miles Kahn.
对于所有收听广播的人，我们的现场电影活动包括克里斯·威尔（Chris Ware）制作的一部极其悲伤和美丽的动画短片。你们可以在网上观看。还可以看到我们制作的额外视频。大卫·拉科夫（David Rakoff）、戴夫·希尔（Dave Hill）、迈尔斯·卡恩（Miles Kahn）。
Our web site www.thisamericanlife.org.
我们的网站 www.thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is distributed by the fine folks at Public Radio International. Support for This American Life is provided by Kashi. Tips on healthy snacking, creating a green kitchen, natural recipes and more at Kashi.com. Kashi. Seven whole grains on a mission. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss Mr. Torey Malatia, who is so easy to beat at Grand Theft Auto.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台的优秀同事发行。《美国生活》的支持来自Kashi。在Kashi.com获取健康零食、打造绿色厨房、自然食谱等方面的建议。Kashi。七种全谷物，肩负使命。WBEZ对我节目的管理监督由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，他在《侠盗猎车手》（Grand Theft Auto）游戏中太容易被我打败了。
Aw man, I had a sip of beer. I don't know where I'm driving from or where I'm driving to.
噢伙计，我喝了一口啤酒。我不知道我是从哪里开过来的，也不知道我要开到哪里去。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
PRI, Public Radio International
国际公共广播电台（PRI）